[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome very much
to the inaugural talk about the AI hub
we're very excited on behalf of AI
platform team to share what we've been
working on over the last year really
quickly some housekeeping items for
those of you who have not used the Dory
application for questions please feel
free to enter your questions there and
vote on questions we have a lot to demo
today so I don't know that we're gonna
have time at the end of the presentation
to answer questions over you know face
to face but we will be but till and and
Lily here will be answering questions in
real-time during the show as well as
afterwards we'll continue to add the
answers to the Dory app so really
quickly the data that the AI platform
team has been very very focused on
trying to solve real world machine
learning problems for our customers and
as we've been talking to customers over
and over and over again we hear three
main concerns every single time the
first one is people have trouble
managing infrastructure whenever you're
talking about machine learning you've
got GPUs TPU CPUs you have to do
distributed training it's kind of a
nightmare sometimes and some people
would rather not do it some people just
can't in addition the real world is
hybrid there's stuff on cloud their
stuff on Prem anytime you have one of
those boundaries it gets to be a little
bit of a nightmare trying to move
workloads from one to the other that's a
problem that we want to solve the second
problem we hear is really about a talent
problem there's just not enough talent
to go around you've got a data scientist
you've got production engineers that are
used to putting those machine learning
jobs into production there's just not
enough so we need to figure out how to
create 10 times force multipliers for
those teams so they can do 10 times more
projects and really enable and empower
your organizations to do that we need
collaboration tools that actually focus
on reuse and collaboration across teams
and essentially create a center of
excellence within your organizations to
meet your needs so that's the theme
you're going to hear over and over again
this talk the third problem that we keep
hearing is people are having tough time
getting started and the reason is
because machine learning is a very large
area of learning and so some people are
new to cloud some people are learned are
new to machine learning some people are
new to specific techniques within
machine learning or to putting those
jobs into production each one of those
has a different learning front and so
the question is how do each of us get
started more quickly so how does cloudy
I help we have a number of new products
we're launching today including the AI
hub along with our new managed notebooks
and we're going to demo a number of
these today as well as our coop flow
fairing system which will also demo as
well really quickly one of the things to
remember is AI is really a team sport if
you've ever seen an organization put a
machine learning model into production
it usually takes a database expert the
Machine the actual subject matter expert
the data scientist and somebody from the
production engineering teams to actually
get this to all work together so you
really need to make sure they're all
working together so if we think about
this each person has a role to do in a
company that role or that person might
have a different skill set they need
different tools to be able to do their
job so the question is is how do we make
each one of these roles each one of
these people successful using machine
learning in the way that they need to to
do their job so really quickly to make
sure we're all talking on the same on
the same page let's talk really quickly
about the the cloud machine learning
stack at the base level at the
foundation level we all are building on
infrastructure right so whether it's
compute or storage or processing
elements could be on Prem or on GC B
does not really matter that's the the
basic legal block that you're working
with
above that GCP has a number of managed
services to make your lives easier
whether it's spending up a virtual
machine to get your jupiter notebooks
going or to do training and/or serving
those are services to make it easier for
you to manage your infrastructure or
if you choose to manage your own
infrastructure we can make creating the
kubernetes cluster is easier with gke
most data scientists actually spend
their life above that stack more on the
tooling and sdk level so we're we're
talking about the notebooks we're
talking about poo flow pipelines for
orchestrating workloads and poop flow
fairing is a new service which will
demonstrate a little bit later today
which enables you to take the same
training code and run it locally on your
VM or with a small amount of
configuration change to make that run in
a distributed fashion on machine
learning infrastructure on Google where
we spin up the machines you do the job
and then we'll tear it down for you
automatically or you can end up having
it run on any kubernetes cluster that
you choose whether it's on Prem or a GCP
in a true hybrid fashion and at the top
of the stack is the AI hub what what the
AI hub really is is a collaboration tool
where you can find then use and then
share any AI asset that you guys need to
do your job obviously Google is
providing some some of those assets to
share some of our partners will be
sharing as well but it's also a place
for you to put your own assets that
don't get shared with anybody except
within your organization that way you
can actually start to share and
collaborate across the teams and have
these teams actually go much much faster
so instead of having 12 different teams
doing OCR very differently you get one
team doing OCR very very well and each
of the other 11 then configuring it for
your clients to me so really briefly one
of the the patterns that you're going to
see is we want the AI hub to be a center
of excellence so that for every single
one of your people we want a familiar
pattern of discovering what you want to
do the detect the asset to actually help
you do that then you go use it you when
you actually get something trained or
working then you can share that back
with your team that could be a model
that could be a notebook or that could
be a pipeline and we'll see this later
on and that
in the demonstration so today the
demonstrations that we're going to be
giving will be focused on these three
personas or users first of all the app
developer who's trying to put some
intelligence into their app how do they
do that easily it will be about the data
scientist who's trying to create a new
training algorithm using a notebook
using different assets from the hub and
then once they've got it trained sharing
it back with their team or the ml
engineer now that they've got a pipeline
how do they configure that pipeline how
do they then deploy it how do they
monitor it so first of all let's talk
about the building the smart apps so I'm
going to be jumping be in and out of the
the presentation so just just to warn
you so the first thing that we've done
is we've put all of cloud a I api's into
the hub so that really easy to find so
you can see right here that they're
they're highlighted as services so you
can see all of the different api's here
so let's say for example I'm building a
smart out and I get users to submit
photos to me I might need to understand
what the heck that photo is whether it's
a cat or a car or is there something
that's maybe not family safe in it so I
can click on the vision API here I can
quickly visit the products page for that
product
and I might need to change the
resolution here and there's a demo right
here that you do really quickly so we
can click on that and I've got a photo
right here that a friend gave me and I
have to say that I'm not a robot and off
it goes and so it is actually done
bounding boxes on a couple of people in
the photo that it's identified if you
look at labels it's identified it
correctly as a baseball park if you look
at the web entities it's actually
identified this as the Oracle park here
just down the street so it's correctly
actually identified the location of this
photo and if you go to the safe search
you can tell that it's it's fine to
share publicly so that's actually really
if you're an app developer and you just
need to consume some of these services
in addition there are times when you as
a developer might have data that's
labeled but you don't know necessarily a
whole lot about machine learning and you
might need to customize that model for
your case let's say you're a
manufacturer you know the the vision API
is gonna be able to tell the difference
between tables and benches and screws
and bolts but it not might not be able
to identify all 10,000 parts on your
warehouse lines so in order to do that
you would supply the images from your
repos and you would go to auto ml and
here's the auto ml vision right here
it's a beta service and from here it
then walks you through the process of
giving the data identifying the problems
and the labels you're trying to solve
and puts it in your own project and then
it will find the right machine learning
model for your problem and optimize that
model and then give it back to you as a
developer you don't have to know what's
going on inside it you've just given it
all the parameters to do your job and
it's actually quite simple to use okay
so the next journey we're gonna talk
about is now as a data scientist now as
a data scientist like we mentioned
before one of the big problems we find
is it's often hard to get started on a
new problem you might be an expert in
one thing and then your boss gives you
another problem to work on and you have
to go figure out how to do that so we
have a number of great notebook samples
in the hub and so right here I've
identified these are all the notebooks
and so maybe I want to there's a fun one
like let's say I want to do style
transfers so I can look for style
transfers and here's an audio style
transfer here's a 3d style transfer this
one's kind of fun so basically you can
take a 3d asset you give it a texture
and then it applies that texture to that
3d asset so you can imagine in gaming or
entertainment areas this might be
something that's interesting you see
this quite a bit and you can go off and
kick that off in a notebook and go mess
with the code and change it and share it
back with your with your
or let's see maybe instead you want to
do you got structured data and maybe
it's in bigquery or something like that
and you want to be able to do gradient
boosted decision trees so you'll be
using XG boost well right here you have
a pipeline or
if we want to restrict it to notebooks
you can restrict notebook and here's an
example of how to use XG boost using
coupe flow faring which is that service
we're going to demonstrate a little bit
later that shows you how to train it and
then deploy that on different locations
okay so just so you can see how it works
here is the notebook right here I can
click open and GCP we now have a new
managed service so that we automatically
spin up a jupiter notebook for you on a
VM on GCP to make that easier and no
more DevOps need to go manage that you
can either create it in a new VM or use
an existing one for speed I'm just gonna
use an existing one
I can click continue it spins up but
I've been using this demo VM and so here
it is and so you can go ahead and run
that if you'd like and so what you can
see here's all the standard code to be
able to read your inputs etc okay
and we'll talk about that in a second
so another thing that the hub does is it
isn't added in a bunch of great support
for transfer learning now one of them
the critical problems we hear about over
and over again is is about a lack of
data so if you're trying to do an image
classification model for instance you
may not have millions of images but you
might have a hundred or two hundred or a
thousand for your particular problem
well how do you solve this problem
the the the technique of transfer
learning is a way that you can use an
open-source pre-trained model that has
been trained on a general data set to
learn the general features and then you
can then switch over to your data set
and fine-tune it on your data to get a
really quick trading to quit really
quickly train on your problem
and so we have a number of these here
and so you can see in the hub how do I
do that well let's go to the tensorflow
modules and so here's a bunch of
different ones and let's say I want
image classification and so here's the
inception v3 embedding here's mobile net
a little bit later on down there's
ResNet okay so let's say we want ResNet
so here's one of the classic embeddings
right here so you can see the original
paper where it was published in 2015 so
you can go learn about it down here is
the code that you can copy and paste to
put into your notebook to make that
really easy from a boilerplate
perspective or the tensorflow team has
made it really easy to copy and paste
with a URL so you basically what you do
is you go click that URL and now to make
it simple I'm gonna jump to a notebook
that's already got the boilerplate in it
so you can see how that's used okay
so right here let's assume that I'm a
cancer researcher and I might have some
images of cancer cells and non cancer
cells and I want to be able to tell the
difference between these and I want to
use that ResNet 50 embedding that I just
saw well I can look at this notebook
here and I do the the common updates of
my libraries and set up my environment
and convert the images of TF record so
it works better with tensorflow all
standard stuff I can visualize some of
these images really quickly just to make
sure that I've done it properly I then
set up my model and you can see right
here that's the URL of the embedding
that you just copied and pasted the rest
of that code around it is the
boilerplate code that the tensorflow
team has provided for you to just use
that and then what you do is you wrap
that in a one layer Karras Network so
it's got one output for binary you know
cancer or not cancer and you'll
basically be ingesting that embedding
from the
answer flow module and train tree and
refining that model using your data that
you supplied to it it's really really
simple to do to do and then basically
here's what you do to using it wrapped
in a Python class you go ahead and go
train on it in that VM or now if you're
using coop flow faring all you have to
do is provide a few parameters about
where's your docker registry where is
your DCP project and give it the the
base docker image and then with Ferenc
you specify the gke back-end on GCP
where you want to go run it and then
submit the job and it goes and runs it
on your gke cluster as as its set up or
instead of running it on gke you may
choose to use the AI factory training
service which used to be called ml
engine up to up until this morning and
with that service we set up the cluster
for you we distribute that we take care
of all the infrastructure it goes and
trains when it's done we tear it down
and you only use for the services that
you use okay so that's a great way to do
it we also have demonstrations at how to
use prediction from it okay so think now
that you are a data scientist and you're
actually training in a hybrid
environment you're training on your VM
wherever you are you're training on
cloud either at a managed or an
unmanaged situation or if you want you
can create configurations for running
those on any cluster you want on pram or
any other hybrid cloud that you might ok
so now that I've got my model trained
and I've got my notebook working I want
to go share that with my team so we
provided directly in the service the
publication capabilities so you can
share it with your team this publish
button is not to publish to the world
it's to publish within your workgroup ok
and you have quick ways so you can see
all the assets that you've created and
these filters down here if I can get rid
of that
oops that doesn't do it okay so there it
goes away
okay I'm gonna jump straight to the app
so I can show you how to do this live if
I click on this publish you can choose
to share a pipeline which we'll talk
about later Sasha will show us that a
trained model that just the wait files
or the notebook itself I'm going to
demonstrate the notebook so let's say
that if this is the cancer demo notebook
and from a data type this is image so
I'm setting up the metadata to make it
easier to find for remembers your team
and this is a training workflow maybe
it's a transfer learning from a labeling
perspective and from a summary this is
use ResNet 50 to train an image
classification model for cancer
detection if I can type there you go
click Next I can now upload a file and
I've got this file right here on my
desktop I open it I click Next it can
now preview it and then I click publish
oops and if I don't get that error then
it basically shares to the rest of your
work group and they can start using it
okay so for with that I'd like to turn
the time over to Venky Rao who is one of
the AI principals at Accenture and he's
going to talk about this experience
within the the Accenture workflow thanks
Justine Venky Roth from Accenture I work
in applied intelligence organization
with an accent or at applied
intelligence you know we help our
clients drive new business outcomes
using analytics automation and AI we we
have a large team of data scientists
over 3,000 data scientists across the
globe and we also bring in
a foundation of data services and that
are pretty unique to to the industry in
which you know we we have relationships
with over 200 data providers and we also
have curated data sets in various
industries that's pretty unique to to us
and then we have strategy consultants
you know who are deep experts in various
industries you know together with all
these capabilities you know that's how
we drive a new business outcomes for our
clients now when it comes to AI hub we
are super excited because you know with
the size and complexity of applied
intelligence team at Accenture we are
constantly looking for new tools in
other will help our data scientists in a
collaborate and and you know speed up
our projects and improve efficiency and
all of that so when you know we saw AI
hub it it really fit into the needs of
our organization and I'm going to show
you how we are using it so one of things
you know I forgot to mention was you
know you know India signs there are a
lot of repeatable processes and there
are a lot of steps you know that you
could share from one project to the
other and a lot of times you know you
you you come in with your data set and
you have a hypothesis and you want to
experiment faster a lot of times you
know we find teams kind of you know
doing the same thing or an Oregon and
and with AI hub if there's a nice
catalog that they can look up and and
include you know those assets into their
projects and build you know pipelines
quickly that's a big win for us and and
that's what we see you know with AI hub
also so I'm going to show you a while
Justin showed you how a I have
looks you know the public view of AI hub
as a customer how does it look now for
you so so this is the public view that
Justin showed and this is the restricted
view which is you know Accenture's in a
view this is where we have published a
few of our assets you know within
applied intelligence you know we have
literally hundreds of notebooks that
that are that can be useful for our
project teams there are pre-trained
models you know and various other assets
and that's how we surface them you know
here within AI hub let's say no let's
and you can see that the icon there it
shows that this is only it's a
restricted thing and it's only available
for our organization because you know
you have to be careful and you can't
even actually you know publish this to
the public view anyways but you know you
can let's say you know I'm interested in
this particular notebook see this is a
great example of a shareable asset one
things that we encourage our data
scientists is to know when they get a
new data set to make sure that they
apply some of the responsible AI
principles that an a we encourage in
this particular case let's say I'm
interested in and understanding how my
data distribution is instead of you know
writing all of that tooling once again
and I could easily look at this and as
Justin showed you know I can actually
bring this up within a VM instance
right so I can select this here yeah
I've already opened one here so you can
see that this is a nice notebook for
data scientists and to quickly take a
look at it now you can run it and then
start changing it and then making it
useful for their own use case so we we
find this in an extremely useful it's
all one click you know deployment of
these notebooks and and it really speeds
up the whole process so we are super
excited about this so I hope you can
start to see the the power of being able
to put best practices in your own
private section of the hub to share
within your organization and get
everybody aligned on best practices
whether it's for fairness or
recommendations or fraud detection or
whatever it might be that your
organization cares about now within
Google we we do something similar as
well and so for instance these TF
modules that we use we use those
millions of times a day on all sorts of
products throughout Google for the
notebooks we share those best practices
as well and with pipelines we have
introduced a concept to do industrial
Google grade pipelines both in and out
of Google and Sasha will come up and
talk about this and while he's coming
really quickly one of the complaints
that customers often talk to us about is
why the heck does it take so is it so
much work to get a machine learning
model into production
I created this model in three weeks ten
months later I'm still fighting with my
DevOps team do you actually get it going
and well the reason is because there's
so many pieces of the process around the
model weights that actually are really
critical to make sure it works you need
to make sure that your your data that
streams that are coming in in production
are actually the same distributions and
not distorted from what you trained the
data
you need to make sure that you've got
the infrastructure right you need to
make sure you got enough RAM so the
things don't die you need to be able to
scale up to handle any arbitrary volume
so you've got you need to be able to do
a/b testing to make sure that any time
that you make a change that your canary
it and making sure no something doesn't
break there's a whole lot that goes into
making sure that this actually works you
don't get disasters on your hands right
well the the tf-x team created ways to
understand each step of pipelines and
the Kubb flow pipelines team created a
way to orchestrate these workflows and
so Sasha will now come up and talk about
that thanks Justin
I'm Sasha sovereign I'm an engineer a
machine learning engineer on the AI hub
team and I'm gonna talk about how AI hub
can jump-start your coop flow pipelines
so what is coop flow pipelines gufo
pipelines is a container orchestration
framework for production and to end
machine learning it comes with a rich UI
that you can use to interact with Kufa
pipelines as well as a Python SDK for
more programmatic execution it covers
the full machine learning lifecycle from
data all the way to serving your train
model so let's say I'm a machine
learning engineer at my company ok and I
have all our data in bigquery and I want
to take that data and I want to use it
for machine learning one of the best
models to use for tabular data is XG
boost and it's usually a good starting
point for a lot of engineers the next
step I want to take is after training
that model I want to deploy it to AI
platform prediction so then I can make
an API available to the rest of my team
so let's talk about how the content that
we've created for AI hub can fit into
that use case all right so fir
we have ready to go pipeline templates
okay these are full end-to-end pipelines
that you can just bring your data fill
the parameters and deploy them next we
have example pipelines and so these are
our reference pipelines that give you a
good idea of what kind of the best
practices for machine learning are and
then we have broken down components
so each pipeline is composed of multiple
components and we've created this suite
of components at multiple steps of the
machine learning lifecycle this includes
pre-processing for your ETL jobs
training for any out-of-the-box model
you want to use that you don't feel like
coding up or if you have your own
in-house and proprietary models in your
favorite machine learning library then
you can use our distributed frameworks
that work out of the box you just
provide your model next is the push to
production okay so once we actually
create that machine learning artifact we
want to put it in a place that it can be
used so going back to that use case of
I'm going from bigquery and I want to
use XG boost and then I want to deploy
to production so let's see how a iHub
can help me do that
I will click out to AI hub okay I've
already set the filters here for public
assets so we're only looking at what's
publicly available next I've also set
the filter for queue flow pipelines so
this will show me cupola pipelines and
components and I said I wanted to run an
extra boost trainer so let's search okay
so right away we can see that we already
have a good amount of content with
relation to XG boost okay we have an
extra boost trainer in spark we have an
extra boost trainer that takes advantage
of GPUs and it's also distributed and
all that is handled under the covers
so the first asset that came up well
training XG boost model using data from
bigquery so let me go check that out in
our documentation we kind of give you a
quick overview of what a component does
so you can quickly figure out if you
actually need to use this or not so here
we can see it selects training and
validation data sets from bigquery
awesome it trains an XG boost model just
what I wanted and then it will deploy
that model to AI platform prediction so
let's go ahead and use this model we
simply go up here and download the model
or sorry the pipeline and then let's
jump to cube flow so this is coop flow
okay it runs on kubernetes it can run on
any kubernetes engine that you like okay
including GK and this one was deployed
using the one click deploy feature of
queue flow you just go to our UI and you
click deploy and you have a queue flow
up and running so pipe lines is a part
of coop flow I just selected it on the
left and this is the initial dashboard
into pipelines and it shows you all your
pipelines
we've already seated a few in here's
that you can see and let's go ahead and
add that pipeline I just downloaded so
I'm gonna pick a pipeline and then let's
go ahead and rename this to BQ 2 XG
boost all right go down and upload so
this will add this pipeline to my
deployment now I can go click on it and
I'll hide this here alright and I'm
gonna zoom out just so you can kind of
get a view of the full pipeline so this
is a four step pipeline it grabs your
bigquery queries for both your training
your validation here and here and will
then use that data it pipes that data
into our extra boost distributed trainer
and then deploys that model so one thing
to know here is that this pipeline is
was completely composed
all our individual components which are
also available on a hub so if you like
any of these components you can take
them out and use them in your own
pipeline so to run this pipeline I just
hit create run I give it a name okay and
then I go down and I fill in parameters
okay and so this is very straightforward
and will get you running very fast now
in interest of time I've went ahead and
ran this pipeline earlier okay and so
let's go take a look at the output of
that so experiments is the place you go
to to see where all your runs have
occurred now an experiment is a logical
grouping of runs so let's say that you
have a production pipeline you run it at
some type of schedule this is a place
that you can group those together to see
kind of how your production system is
changing over time so for this
particular experiment I've only run this
one pipeline as a demonstration okay and
I can click on it and now I can see that
my pipeline is successfully executed
each of these checkmarks comes in and I
can go and look at the logs for each of
my pipe for each of my steps looking my
evaluation errors as they're logged out
and finally I can actually get my model
endpoint in AI platform prediction so
let's take a step back and go back to AI
hub okay so let's say I'm don't want to
use XG boost and I actually do a lot of
my work in tensor flow one of the big
frameworks that google recently fully
open sourced is t FX which is tensorflow
extended it's basically a production
machine learning pipeline tailor-made
for tensorflow it's a Google grade and
that means that it runs a majority of
the machine learning pipelines inside of
Google as well and now you can take
advantage of it the value at here is
that a I hub we host a reference
I plan for you to look at you can also
use that reference pipeline to then see
how your workflows should change so
let's check that out
so here's T effects okay and the first
thing that comes up is this TFM a
taxicab classification example so let's
click on that and take a look so this
reference pipeline it uses T effects for
the use case of trying to predict
taxicab predictions or start trying to
predict whether or not someone will tip
a taxicab so let's say I'm interested in
using this pipeline as a reference
pipeline I can download it let's go back
to the cube flow UI and go to pipelines
and when I just simply upload the
pipeline again so one thing to note here
is that I don't have to use the UI I can
use the Python SDK if I want more
programmatic execution and entry point
into cube flow pipelines so let's take a
look at this pipeline and so this one's
a little bit more complex than the last
one we saw and it has many steps
including a validation of data step
pre-processing training and then a model
analysis step a batch prediction step
for a final evaluation and then a
deployment step out to AI platform
prediction so again to respect your time
we've run multiple runs of this pipeline
so let's see how we can use queue flow
pipelines to analyze those runs so let's
go back to the experiments page oh one
second okay alright so we have this taxi
experiment here and I've said earlier
that this is a logical grouping of
pipeline runs okay and right away you
can kind of see that there's a lot of
information here that you can use to
compare these runs
so the first thing to note is that again
let's say if I'm in production okay and
all my runs are succeeding my fourth run
okay
did not succeed I see that right away as
a failed status okay and I can just
click on that and I can see that my data
validation failed so I can click into
this look at the logs troubleshoot fix
and then run the pipeline again now one
of my favorite features of queue flow
pipelines is the ability to aggregate
these runs and then view them all in one
dashboard so let's take a look at that
so first I'm gonna select my runs that
have all succeeded and then I'm gonna go
up here and select compare runs okay so
this is a run comparison dashboard and
let's see what it tells us so first it
gives us things like the duration of the
pipeline okay it also gives us a quick
overview of these high-level machine
learning metrics that we may be
interested in including accuracy and roc
and we can kind of see that run one are
sorry run three marginally performed
better than the other runs here based on
accuracy NRSA so let's go down and see
why that is so this also captures the
parameters that you entered into your
pipeline so it's easy for you to see the
difference here so the only variation
between these three runs was the hidden
layer size and like we said run three
was the best and we can see that the
smallest hidden layer size actually
performed marginally better so these are
important insights that you can pull out
just off this quick view let's go down a
little bit so next and also I love this
is a tensor board okay so for those who
of you who are not familiar tensor board
is a powerful tool for tensor flow it
allows you to deep dive into your model
so that you can see its performance as
it trains it as well as any other type
of metrics you're trying to track now
generally to use tensor board you have
to write all your
models the same directory and kind of
manage that if you want to get
everything together
now what q flow pipelines does is this
able to aggregate all these together all
these runs together into the same tensor
board so then you can easily make
comparisons at once and that's what
we're doing here under this aggregated
view of tensor board so let's open that
up so here is sensor board it's already
running this works out of the box when
you deploy q flow and qu flow pipelines
you don't need to set it up and let's go
down here and let's say I want to look
at my lost curves for all my runs that
is super simple it's written here and I
can go ahead and look run by run what
the lost curves were it also has
everything else you expect from tensor
board including your graphs
distributions and so forth now let's go
back to Q flow and let's go down we can
see we can see there's some other
visualizations that are also very
beneficial confusion matrix for this
problem and then the next thing or the
last thing that I kind of want to
highlight on is that T FMA is also
available through Q flow pipelines and
so what is TF MA so TF MA is a part of T
FX it stands for tensor flow model
analysis so let's break that open so
again Q fo pipelines is a rich UI and it
lets you pop out to the TF ma
visualization so TF MA lets you view
your models performance at different
cross sections of your data so then you
can pinpoint where your model is not
performing very well and then you can
iterate and improve that model this is
extremely powerful as you're trying to
find the best model for your use case so
here we can kind of see everything that
gets back to us the trip start ours was
split up by time and we can see how well
it performed at each at each hour of the
day so let's close that there are a few
more features down the bottom I'm just
going to gloss over them it shows you
the ROC curve right away and then these
tables actually give you a view into
your data that was used to train your
model as well for each of your runs
okay now let's go back to a iHub and so
I hope in summary that you kind of saw
how powerful AI hub and cue flow
pipelines can be when they work together
we have a lot of components and
pipelines already up and available for
you on AI hub that you can use today so
please take a chance to check that out
and now I'll hand it back to Justin
thank you very much Sasha
[Applause]
okay so hopefully by now you've been
able to see how impactful sharing and
finding assets within the hub can be
whether that's your API is that you're
wanting to use within a smart app or
whether it's sample notebooks to be able
to learn how to do new techniques from
from a notebook setting as a data
scientist or from a production
experimentation frame were to be able to
do End and machine learning pipelines in
a scalable industrial fashion and to
really understand how to iterate on
those pipelines and to debug them it's
it's a really fantastic tool all
starting with the hub okay so hopefully
you can see that but we don't want you
to really just take our word for it
we've actually been testing this with a
number of early access partners and we
really want to thank them for all of
their hard work and helping us you know
iterate on this we also have a number of
topics that we've touched on here we
know that we were going lightning fast
so we encourage you to go see any of our
other sister presentations here next or
if you missed some of those they will
all be on on YouTube later on so you can
go watch each one of these presentations
right there as well
and in closing the AI hub is now open as
a beta product for you to use anybody
with a Google account can use any of the
assets there and if you've got a G
Suites account you can easily share that
within your organization and we'll be
rolling out access controls to make that
much more widely available as we see fit
or as you see fit we want to partner
with you we want your feedback this is
the beginning of a joint journey that we
want to do with you so we really value
your feedback there's a feedback button
on the top right-hand side of the hub we
would love for you to submit hey what
you like what you would wish we would
add whatever it is that's a very
valuable feedback for us and we hope to
go on this journey with you if you have
content that you would actually like to
share to the world and publish as part
of the public hub we are completely open
to that and please contact us there's a
forum at the bottom of the hub where you
can actually apply and then we can start
that conversation with you and in
closing we just want to thank you very
much for the opportunity to share this
with you and we hope to talk to you more
[Applause]
[Music]